this Raptors team really for the last 10
games that shot the ball welcome free at
last
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
bring on the chat box yes
28 for siakam tonight essentially
doubling his average Yanis free trip
1917 let's zoo coming right back
Yanis left alone and that's not a good
idea
so in Briscoe personally blood-soaked
coming right back at it
be honest for three flips the ball back
into play quickly to Yanis Manus for
three be honest again you give them the
cushion if you're Jeremy grant you're
not gonna let him shoot it up at a 16
point lead for the Thunder who has the
third best record in the West pathetic
cabal finally his first field gone comes
in the 10 38 mark and it's a three
pointer corner and just smartly
[Applause]
pathetic tune ball four three on the
money splashes it down a second three
spheres Yanis he'll take the three and
make the three it's a four point game
it's a two-minute monkeypox Bucks fight
to the attack early because you did have
that man advantage and an opportunity
for a second chance from the corner it
is so tough to stop it but again look
all the players around three players
around them in the pink now watch the
outcome back up he's gonna say no I
don't want you to get to the paint after
kupo says to try and get it yeah it is
from outside puts it up and through and
then from deep listen this is the last
aspect and when you watch this guy and
we were at shoot around this morning J
we going to pick teammate Chris middle
them too close quote I cannot afford to
have LeBron take him first to try to
play mind games of me
[Applause]
ready eight assists in this game through
Saturday SP is identical Bo well some
players can do it all once in a while he
can do it all every game and has been in
eight years in the league shooting three
threes and then he goes it's a total
treatments like a total transformation
of the player pointers up to three
pointers in tonight for dota and another
creep won't try and Yanis makes that one
that takes a lot of confidence so far in
the game he's wide open a rhythm durable
and it pours
he was hesitate to take that shot on the
initial catch and shoot after took the
fall he will fire the shot confidence up
Japanese he got himself going a little
bit
shut up at BU the Confessor giannis for
the number three point attack this time
he hit and he'll shoot a three again be
honest this side cuts the role right
POTUS has a wall range shooter drowned
in the playoff series they're begging
them we're going to talk about that
tonight too because the Bucks allow
opponents to take threes and we'll get
into that a bit later on Hanna's best
road team with aggressive play a near
steal the Bucks control two on the shot
clock
nanus has to take the game
his second make tonight he has 18.6 off
a Shack watch huh
but it's just not that look where Rudy's
playing so far back that's a big three
you ask how good of a three-point
shooter about twenty three percent on
the year unreal
Mitchell working on a 40 point nine to
the kupo three and time out Quin Snyder
here or this is what you hope you can
get better at than two and if you're
Quinn you're saying listen I will give
you that shot Joseph a valuable member
to the San Antonio Spurs over a long
period of time a vision of three four to
be honest and it's going to retreat
dribble on Marvin Williams be honest
backs out seven on the shot clock three
on the wagon
[Music]
[Applause]
once again dribble pull-up coming down
and semi transition and that you play
better defense of that but kippa walk it
just picking up his mind and try and
change the momentum up go
[Applause]
they have to beat Charlotte here on
something I agree I mean it was so
promising the way they came out of the
gate us we see the Greek freak knocking
down hit trying to take him beat outside
he doesn't come with him so he fires the
three in that time account okay now that
was a about getting him the ball 15 to
18 feet on the either out of the paint
or hitting him in the face young about
those 29 threes you know they're their
second in the league in three attempted
anyway so I said coach I know you guys
shoot a lot anyway but are you good with
twenty